what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and everything
relating to the mcu and of course we are
still talking about spider-man no way
home but today we're actually going to
take it a step further and we're going
to be talking about spider-man 4 the
next installment of the spider-man
franchise and the possibility of andrew
garfield returning and possibly picking
back up where he left off with the
amazing spider-man franchise finally
giving us that amazing spider-man 3 film
now there's a lot of rumors and reports
flying around right now about this some
of them confirmed and some of them are
just rumors for now but don't worry i'll
break down everything that you need to
know in this video and big thank you to
buxu for sponsoring this video and doing
a giveaway more on them in a bit and
also i'm going to break down this video
into two separate parts the first part
is going to be spoiler free for
spider-man knowing home and the second
part and i will mention when i start the
second part we'll have spoilers for no
way home but for now spoiler free and of
course if you love spider-man and the
mcu be sure to subscribe so you can stay
up to date on all things in the mcu okay
so first and foremost let's talk about
the confirmed report that marvel studios
and sony are in fact developing another
spider-man film as we speak in an
interview with the new york times kevin
feige and executive producer for sony
and president of pascal pictures amy
pascal commented on what is next for
spider-man in which kevin feige right
next to amy pascal said amy and i and
disney and sony are talking about
yes we're actively beginning to develop
where the story heads next which i only
say outright because i don't want fans
to go through any separation trauma like
what happened after far from home now if
you're one of the few that doesn't
remember what happened after far from
home it really was kind of traumatic
after far from home came out in the
movie theaters there immediately began
to be talk about spider-man no longer
being a part of the mcu the talk was
that sony pictures were going to take
back spider-man because remember sony
still owns all of the rights to
spider-man marvel studios and sony
simply worked out a deal for spider-man
to be in the mcu and to share some of
the profits but sony still owns those
rights but fortunately for us it looks
like sony and marvel studios have
realized that the best way to go about
making spider-man movies is to keep him
in the marvel cinematic universe and
this all started when kevin foggy went
to amy pascal when she was at sony
saying uh you're gonna have to let us do
it if you want spider-man to be
successful and we need to fully do it
and clearly it's had massive success
spider-man and captain america civil war
spider-man homecoming far from home and
now no way home is blowing up so the
future is bright and kevin feige
confirms they are beginning to work on
the next one and of course since kevin
foggy is saying that it will take place
in the mcu and i'm sure if they didn't
say this a lot of rumors would be flying
around about maybe spider-man's not
going to be in the mcu so i'm really
glad he cleared this up so a new
spider-man film what could this possibly
be about now whether or not you've seen
spider-man no way home it doesn't really
matter because you know that he's in his
senior year we know this from far from
home and we know this from the trailers
so it's not a spoiler to say that this
was his senior year in this movie the
next year is probably going to be in
college which is something we've never
seen on screen before and which is
something that i think would actually be
pretty cool now we could speculate all
day on what could happen but
unfortunately i think some of that will
be spoilers so i'll talk about that in a
bit but not for the non-spoiler part but
let's talk about the possibility of
andrew garfield returning and the
possibility of him maybe finishing his
amazing spider-man trilogy with a
spider-man 3. now these reports are
coming from insiders who have really
good track records last night daniel rpk
tweeted i also hear andrew might come
back then the account my time to shine
hello says that andrew garfield could
actually come back for multiple projects
now we know sony is up to a lot with
their own universe right now with
morbius and venom craven the hunter
we're getting a spider woman film from
olivia wilde they're gonna need their
own spider-man because the story of
peter parker and the mcu seems to be
going a certain direction which i don't
think would go into the sony universe so
perhaps this is where andrew garfield
could come back and the multiple
projects are talking about could be
these projects like craven the hunter
like morbius now we did see the painting
of spider-man on the wall in the morbius
trailer that says murderer over it and
it didn't look like tom holland's
spider-man so maybe it could be andrews
now it actually looked like toby's but
perhaps that's misdirection but the good
news is andrew garfield might return to
complete his amazing spider-man trilogy
and be in other films and i do have
which i personally think is a really
good theory of what exactly sony is
going to do with andrew garfield
spider-man if he returns unfortunately
it involves some spoilers of some things
that doctor strange did in spider-man no
way home so now i'm going to start with
the spoilers spoiler warning if you
haven't seen no way home you should
click away now and real quick and big
thank you to buksu for sponsoring this
video book suit is a premium japanese
snack box subscription service they send
you a new box each month packed with a
bunch of awesome snacks with some of the
most amazing snacks you've ever had in
your life and every month there's a
brand new theme based off of a season
location or holiday in japan and the
snacks come from all over japan from
kumamoto to aomori and they all taste
incredible but in this new box i think
my favorites are the 20th century pear
lang de chat the donden yaki and the
mini red bean crackers now they're all
labeled in japanese completely they are
traditional snacks from japan but they
give you a booklet that tells you
exactly what everything is and what's in
it and get this have you ever wanted to
go to japan if you sign up with voxu
before december 31st you'll be entered
in a giveaway for a chance to win two
tickets to japan sadly this is only
available to us residents and there are
some terms and conditions which i'll put
in the description down below so want
free tickets to japan use my code cosmic
wonder 10 and link to become eligible to
win the giveaway by subscribing to boksu
my code will get you 10 off your
subscription don't miss out on this
unique opportunity available for anyone
who subscribes until december 31st so
since we now are in the portion where
everybody has seen no way home we can
really get into this i have to say
andrew garfield spider-man was one of my
favorite parts of spider-man knowing
home i think he did a fantastic job and
for those people out there who wanted
redemption for andrew garfield
spider-man i think we got it the emotion
that he brought into this film was
insane and when he caught mj i cried but
here's my theory on how he could come
back and be a part of the sony
spider-man universe because i actually
think that after this film they're going
to separate the universes a little bit
more especially after the first post
credit scene for spider-man no way home
so if you recall in the post-credits
scene venom went back to his universe
the sony universe but he left a part of
the symbiote behind which means and we
can probably assume that peter parker
tom holland's peter parker is eventually
going to get the venom symbiote this
kind of makes eddie brock and his venom
irrelevant in the mcu unless they're
planning on having a venomverse venom
fight eventually down the road but that
doesn't look to be the case again like i
stated before it looks like sony has
their own plans with their own
spider-man universe the only problem is
they don't really have a spider-man or
do they was the plan this entire time to
use andrew garfield spider-man in their
own universe after all aiming pascal and
sony were going to make the amazing
spider-man 3 until kevin foggy came
along and said marvel studios needs to
do this but here's my theory i actually
do think we're going to get a venom vs
spider-man i just think that it's going
to be with andrew garfield spider-man
during the venom let there be carnage
press junket tom hardy talked about how
the next movie he wants it to be a venom
vs spider-man film we know morbius
exists in the same universe as venom and
we saw the oz corp building from the
amazing spider-man universe from andrew
garfield's universe and morbius does
reference venom so we know for sure they
are in the same universes in the morbius
trailer we see a picture of spider-man
that is not tom holland spider-man and
now eddie and venom know about
spider-man in the post-credit he
actually mentioned going to new york to
find spider-man and although eddie was
only in the mcu for what maybe a day he
did learn a lot he learned about the
avengers and he learned about spider-man
so it is possible that when he's back in
his universe he goes to new york and he
seeks out spider-man but who's
spider-man would this be it would be
andrew garfield considering all the
evidence that we have so far the same
exact amazing spider-man oscorp logo the
picture of spider-man on the wall that
isn't tom hollands tom hardy talking
about the next venom film being a venom
versus spider-man film even though he
knew he would be in the mcu for only a
moment then be back in his own universe
and now today the reports from very
credible insiders stating that andrew
garfield could be returning for multiple
projects and i think those multiple
projects could exist in the sony
spider-man universe i firmly think that
this is the plan if andrew garfield is
coming back obviously he was in
spider-man no way home and i think many
many many people really loved him in
this film for me he was one of my
favorite parts i absolutely loved seeing
him and of course toby maguire on screen
with tom holland now there is rumors
that toby could return as well but he is
a little bit older so that is a little
bit less likely but we know that andrew
garfield loved playing spider-man and i
think after knowing home a lot of people
are going to really want to see him
return but people of course love tom
holland as spider-man as well and he has
a whole story ahead of him so i think
they're going to split the universes i
really think they're going to just have
tom holland be in the mcu and now andrew
garfield be in the sony universe that's
my theory on how i think it's all going
to happen but let me know what you think
in the comments down below don't forget
to subscribe and of course don't forget
to like the video and for live updates
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter as always thank you all so much
for watching
woof
[Music]
hmm